while we're going through this rough  time together I thought I'd give you  some tips on how to help your community  and now it's time for Conan's good  neighbor tips  today's tip if you have too much of  something share it like today I'm gonna  give away some of this extra toilet  paper to my neighbors / zoom hey  neighbors you ready for some extra TP  here you go Chris thanks Conan Kaffee TP  coming at you wait how did you hey Diane  some for you oh Jesus flinch my pleasure  Ronnie get ready what Wow volunteering  feels so good thanks for being a good  neighbor Conan sort of and Stephan wants  to say thanks to everyone all over the  country who's being a good neighbor  right now that's a beautiful sentiment  now get your branded messaging out of my  sketch Jake from State Farm this has  been Conan's good neighbor tips